this is why people hate Ticketmaster so
I woke up early to get these tickets I
was in the queue early and waiting for
the on sale time to come and immediately
what I noticed is that the entire
stadium is verified resale ticket why
would they already be selling resale
tickets when these tickets literally
just went on sale despite all the
criticism over the last few years have
not gotten any kind of handle on their
bot scalping problem so I obviously want
to be on the ga floor who are these
people going to a concert and they just
sit in the chairs it tells me another
fan got my tickets this isn't my first
Ticketmaster Rodeo so I think it started
around 140 I got kicked out I came back
and it was around 160 because they're
resale tickets so this just slowly went
up the entire time until finally I got
through and I was able to get my tickets
for over 200 and it's just ridiculous
that it has to be like this Ticketmaster
has been criticized for years now and it
seems like no improvements have been
made if anything the the ticket buying
process has gotten worse I know the
rewards going on right now but a
YouTuber needs to see a post hardcore
show let me know your Ticketmaster
horror stories in the comments